i reacted to medical scenes from family
guy and nearly 10 million of you said
more so here we go huge thank you to
shipstation for sponsoring this video
hello my name's johnny knoxville and i'm
going to take a shotgun blast to the
face
that's literally what the show is though
especially lately you know what we
should try some of that stuff no you
shouldn't every episode says that these
are trained stunt professionals and
there are medical professionals standing
by i'm peter griffin and this is
shopping cart
roof roof roof shop roof shopping cart
that's how a lot of the names of the
things are okay go
oh ow
ow
oh
that is not a normal configuration of
peter's body what does it look like wha
what do i do it looks like your your
vertebral bodies have shifted that's a
spinous process out backwards i'm scared
i'm scared i'm scared
oh how did you just get fixed with ice
or heat uh no er with a c collar and a
rapid ct scan your blood work shows that
your liver isn't functioning properly
now the most obvious step would simply
be to stop drinking
or
well that's the most obvious step a lot
of times we see a pattern on the
inflammatory liver enzymes where the ast
is double the alt that can signal that
potentially it's alcohol-induced liver
injury well we do have these pills that
may correct the enzyme imbalance in your
liver we don't have that for alcohol and
do sliver entry that doesn't exist can
we do what we normally do where you roll
it up in a piece of cheese like you're
fooling me yeah i guess but then you're
gonna have cheese in your ass
what see i did this whole video where i
was telling people how i give bear
capsules and everyone's like just put it
in cheese but if it's a capsule the dog
can't chew it otherwise all the powder
that's inside the capsule spills out so
capsules you gotta trick them the way
that i do it is just shove it down bears
throat yeah the doctor said i gotta give
you these pills to butt way oh no no no
no no no no that is not happening why
don't they just say suppository why does
he say butt way
[Music]
what the hell you
you bit me for dog bites a broad
spectrum antibiotic like augmentin and
make sure your tetanus is up to date
your tetanus vaccine i mean mrs griffin
it's a good thing you brought this child
in why is he okay i'm afraid he's very
sick in fact his lab work shows he's
suffering from hodgkin's lymphoma that
wouldn't be just a a lab diagnosis are
you saying scotty has cancer i don't
know i didn't read the whole wikipedia
entry but the good news is that what he
has is highly treatable by the way
people judge doctors for looking things
up we can't maintain all of the
information in our minds nor is it
useful because a lot of the guidelines
which we use to make decisions on what
to do change and they change based on
the newest evidence and research comes
out a mile a minute so you can't keep up
with all of it so if your doctor looks
things up to be thorough and careful
that's a good thing
oh for god's sake look do you have any
idea how expensive medical school is no
i don't well it's probably pretty
expensive probably pretty expensive you
didn't go to med school you don't need
to tip your doctor in fact i think
giving your doctor anything worth more
than 30 is considered unethical or maybe
even illegal but what i will say is that
the cost of health care going up has
very little to do with doctor salaries
and all almost everything to do with the
rise of administrators back to family
guy in just a second but first i want to
talk to you about ship station look this
last year i've dealt with so many
headaches and shipping things like my
new merch so i get the struggle of
running your own online business but
thanks to shipstation small business
owners like myself finally have time to
do more of what we really love their
order management and software automate
so many steps of the shipping process
giving me more time to treat patients
make youtube videos or train for my next
boxing opponent from the dashboard i can
easily import orders from amazon ebay
etsy even my own website and automate
just about every shipping task even for
my phone they work with international
and local shipping companies around the
world like fedex and ups and i even get
access to discounted rates that are
usually reserved for fortune 500
companies all without the contracts or
commitments over a hundred thousand
sellers are already using shipstation
and 98 of companies that use them for a
year keep using them as long as they're
in business it's time to let go of all
those shipping tasks shipstation can do
it better and faster sign up now for a
60-day free trial visit shipstation.com
dr mike remember doctor is spelled out
and starts saving time on every shipment
that's two whole months of shipping made
quick and painless it's free to try just
go to shipstation.com dr mike all right
let's get back to the family guy now you
see that barbell over there go ahead and
try and lift that
yeah two-year-old should not be
powerlifting in the gym i got something
that'll get them going
oh my god well if there's anyone i can
trust it's a stranger at the gym holding
a dirty needle here stewie try this i
feel like when people go to the gym they
suspend all skepticism if a person is
jacked so like if you see a person
that's jacked you're like every piece of
advice they are giving is the equivalent
of a certified phd athletic trainer
giving it to you most cases it's just
bro science well will you look at me
i have the power
hello family why his legs so weak though
get some symmetry bruh hey what the hell
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa is there a
problem huh you wanna go you wanna go
testosterone rage steroid rage actually
real and does happen what are you
talking about i'm talking about go
that's what i'm talking about first
one's on the house one of the side
effects to enhance exposure to
testosterone is that you are willing to
take on more risk not even that you just
get angry you are literally willing to
put your life in danger you start
driving more aggressively you start
speeding more all the things that you
associate with kids doing when they're
having peak levels of testosterone is
what happens stewie did you hire three
mexican guys to shake a soda can and
give it to my boss what
one's guatemalan damn it stewie you got
me fired get your hands off me i'll go
floppy dead weight on you
ah ah crap my stomach i think my hernia
ruptured the danger with hernias is less
about rupture and more about
incarceration of bowels where the bowels
actually poke through the hernia then
get strangulated because the hernia cuts
off circulation to the piece of the
bowel that went through and then
essentially chokes it out and has it die
that's a medical emergency because if
you don't correct that you can die from
it outside of what common knowledge
might be that if you have a big hernia
it's more likely to get choked out
that's not true it's actually the small
hernias that have a higher rate of
incarceration rather than the big ones
the big ones are usually the reducible
ones that you could just like push the
abdominal contents back in
oh
oh god buddy i'm sorry you okay
why is the chicken always here
[Music]
i don't know why these cartoons they
always show the facial trauma as like
tic-tac-toe squares on their faces
[Music]
i don't know what's a better fight this
or me versus i don't
the blunt force drama that both of them
have experienced is really impressive
that they keep going
when you get electrocuted by the way
your body doesn't light up like an x-ray
where you can see your bones i hope that
goes without saying i feel like a lot of
thc was consumed in the creation of this
clip and that's my medical opinion three
adults and one infant please nice try
lady that kid's at least three what
that's insane
brian do i look old do you you look fine
the museum man just said i looked over
too that's mid toddler actually that's
something we do in the doctor's office
when a patient comes in part of our
objective thing is patient appears
stated age or patient appears older than
stated age stewie what the hell did you
do to yourself nothing almost nothing
just a little botox a little filler
maybe some strings so cute let me guess
10 months
oh my god my new look is working i'm
back into months he should have just
used an instagram filter like everybody
else stewie you got more plastic surgery
i know it was a mistake doctor this is
stewie he needs you to help fix his face
oh absolutely i can do that great is it
a simple procedure oh sure we just break
every bone in his face and then smoosh
him back into position or you could use
uh the dissolving liquid for the fillers
wow dr hartman really did a good job yep
he told me bed rest and ice packs for
two days so it can set but i'm not
missing picture day ah you sure you
shouldn't listen to the doctor brian i
know what i'm doing one
two
three
you know we're laughing and attacking
botox here but the reality is botox
actually has some medical utility in
times where we want to shut down the
activity of an overactive muscle we can
use botox i've seen it used quite
successfully for migraines certain types
of spasms jaw tightness like tmj so
there are utilities outside of cosmetic
purposes
i actually immigrated to the us from
russia when i was six years old in this
video i tell that whole story with full
animation click there to check that out
also don't miss out on your 60-day free
trial to shipstation by visiting
shipstation.com dr mike and as always
stay happy and healthy